الرئيس الاوكراني فلوديمير في قلم من
جانبه ان الدفاع عن بخموت مهم ولكن ليس
باي ثمن مؤكدا ان الوضع على جبهه صعب
للغايه ولكن القوات الاوكرانيه تلحق
بروسيا خسائر فادحه
تعمل مع حلفائها على تقويه العقوبات على
روسيا حسب قوله
ودارس على جبهه الوضع صعب للغايه نصارع
العدو ونلحق خسائر فادحه بروسيا وكلما
خسرت روسيا في دون باس باخموت وفوجليدار
ومارينكا وكريمنا اسرعنا في انهاء هذه
الحرب بانتصارنا نعمل مع شركائنا على
تقويه العقوبات المفروضه على الارهاب
تحدثت مع الرئيس الفرنسي بشان مزيد من
الدعم الدفاعي لحمايه شعبنا واوروبا
باسرها
للمزيد حول الاوضاع الميدانيه وتحديدا في
ينضم الينا من كراماتورست مراسلة الجزيره
عامر اللافي نريد ان نفهم ماذا تقول كيف
فيما يتعلق بالمعارك الدائره في باخمه
الان
نعم عبد السلام يعني رسميا لا يوجد
تصريحات بخصوص رد على هذه التصريحات
الروسيه التي تتحدث عن انه تم تطويق محمود
فقط قياده الاركان اكتفت بالحديث عن صبها
للعديد من الهجمات حول مخمود وبان القوات
الاوكرانيه توقع خسائر كبيره في صفوف
القوات الروسيه هناك لكن نحن طبعا تحدثنا
مع مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه في مخمود ونفو
لنا نفيا قاطعا ان تكون قد تم
ان كانت القوات الروسيه من تطويق هذه
المدينه نعم يعترفون بان الوضع صعب وصعب
جدا لكنهم يصفونه بانه تحت السيطره نعم
يقولون بان القوات الروسيه تتقدم وخصوصا
في المحور الشمالي وبعد سيطرتها على قريه
باراس كوفيفكا تقدمت نحو قريه ايضا يهدني
وتمكنت من اختراق الدفاعات الجنوبيه لبرس
كوفيفكا لكنها توقفت هناك بسبب القصف
المدفع الشديد الذي تعرضت له من المدفع
الاوكرانيه قالت لنا هذه المصادر بان
المدفعيه الاوكرانيه تؤلم المهاجمين بشكل
كبير هي اوقفتهم الان في المحور الشمالي
واوقفته منذ فتره في المحور الجنوبي تعلم
القوات الروسيه ايضا تحاول التقدم من
الجنوب لقطع الطريق الواصل قطع الطريق
الرئيسي الواصل بين قسطنطنيه وهي ما زالت
تعجز عن التقدم هناك وقالوا ايضا وفقا
طبعا لهذه المصادر بان يعني خسائر كبيره
وقعت في صفوف القوات الروسيه عبد السلام
نحن اصلا كنا قد دخلنا لمدينه محمود قبل
عده ايام صعوبه الوضع هناك رايناه باعيننا
تعلم الحرب في مخمود ومحاوله السيطره
عليها لم تبدا اليوم او امس منذ عده شهور
والقوات الروسيه تحاول التقدم دخلنا هذه
المدينه اكثر من مره وكنا في كل مره
نستخدم الطرق الرئيسيه كنا نصل الى مركز
هذه المدينه لكن هذه المره لم نتمكن سوى
من الدخول الى الاحياء الغربيه من المدينه
وعبر طرق الالتفافيه صعبه لكي نتمكن بسبب
صعوبه الوضع
شكرا جزيلا لك على المعلومات وننتقل
مباشره الى
امين درغامي حدثنا عن ما تشاهده انت امين
حيث تقل
نعم ليلى منذ صباح اليوم وبعض الاحيان في
مدينه تتعرض لقصف مدفعي قالت القوات
المواليه لروسيا هنا على انه تركز على
احياء كيرسكي وكيرفسكي هذه الاحياء التي
لا يتوقف القصف عليها طيله النهار وايضا
في بعض ساعات الليل بعد ان كانت المدينه
ايضا يسقط تعرضت امس لقصف صاروخي غير
مسبوق بنحو اربعين صاروخ من طراز جراد كما
قالت السلطات المواليه لروسيا هنا ما ادى
الى مقتل مدني واحد وجرح اثني عشر اخرين
وطبعا تضرر عدد كبير من المنشات البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه
والاداريه لربما هذا القصف المتصاعد والذي
لربما حدته تتزايد يوما بعد اخر يفسر ما
يجري على الجهه الاخرى من خط الجبهه وتح
في محور مدينه بخمس وايضا في محور مدينه
افديفكا المجاوره لمدينه دمياط حيث نحن
الان اليوم التصريحات كانت لافته عن
وهو مستشار رئيس دونيسكن موالي لروسيا
الذي تحدث عن تمكن القوات الروسيه من
محاصره وتطويق مدينه
ضخموت لكنه لربما كان يعني التطويق الناري
والسيطره الناريه على الجزء المتبقي
الغربي الشمالي من هذه المدينه طبعا قال
بان القوات الاوكرانيه سحبت قيادتها
العسكريه الى مدينه
المجاوره وقال بان هناك استماته للقوات
الاوكرانيه في الدفاع عن ما تبقى من مواقع
خاضعه لسيطرتهم لكنه قال بانها غير قادره
على الانسحاب الى تلك المواقع الجديده
لانها غير مجهزه للوقوف امام هجمات الجيش
الروسي كما قال وهناك حديث غير رسمي في
الحقيقه ليلى الان على ان القوات الروسيه
قد تحقق او تسعى على الاقل لتحقيق تقدم
كبير في معركه بخموت قبل حلول الرابع
والعشرين من هذا الشهر وهو ما يصادف
الذكرى الاولى للحرب طبعا باقي
المحاور خاصه الجنوبيه في اوغليدار
القريبه من دونياس كما قلت في ارضيفكا
ايضا تشهد معارك محتدمه بين الجانبين من
الواضح ان هناك ضغط روسي عسكري متواصل على
مواقع الجيش الاوكراني لربما في مسعى الى
يعني ربما تحقيق بعض المكاسب العسكريه على
فكره شكرا جزيلا لك امين درغامي من
دانياسك طبعا وشكرا لعامر لافي